last week I watched and reviewed season
one of mob psycho 100 and it was epic
way better than I ever thought it was
going to be and if you haven't seen it
you can click the link in the top right
but season two is honestly better in
almost every way and I didn't even think
that was possible this season had me on
the edge of my seat and even had moments
that made me cry and it's been a little
bit since that happened so without
further Ado I'm totally nutmmark and
this is my review of the frankly
impossibly brilliant mob psycho 100
season 2.
[Music]
episode one I just uh I love this
episode guys like I need really really
loved it something that I think is often
lost when stories become more
complicated layered and involved
numerous characters is the simple heart
at the core of a very particular set of
ideas and in this case episode I've
pointed this out before but one the
author of this story I'm reviewing has
the ability to write incredibly resonant
and raw emotional scenes the likes of
which will not just take you off guard
but will leave you reeling and mulling
over what you have just seen for days to
come this is such an episode and
honestly episodes like this don't come
around every day
in the case of one punch man's Moomin
Rider versus the Deep Sea King scene the
character is presented as a joke in all
of the episodes that featured prior
someone delusional or perhaps propelled
by ego into dangerous situations within
which he has no chance of survival one
paints him with this brush because he
wants to shine a light on not just who
he is but the greater message of the
series at hand in the world of one punch
man the conflict of interest that exists
within hero Society has created boastful
egocentric or simply misguided Heroes
the likes of which have lost sight of
what makes a hero well a hero and as
movement writer comically Cycles to the
scene of the greatest threat we've yet
seen in the series up until this point
we anticipate failure in spectacular
fashion brought about by perhaps as I
said his own ego or books from nature
and while our expectations for the
conclusion to this interaction were
correct with him losing in spectacularly
one-sided fashion the feeling it left us
with was decidedly unexpected for when
no one else could for the cowering crowd
of men women and little children if only
to buy them a moment of reassurance
movement writer stepped up to the plate
without hesitation stared death in the
eye and dared him to Blink and in the
end while not achieving much of a result
without that initial Sacrifice from
Moomin writer sayatama the person who
does eventually save the day might not
have had the time to arrive on the scene
so in that instance wanting to do the
right thing saved countless lives it
highlighted what was in this Society the
making of a true hero and saitama
recognizes this
the opening episode of mob psycho's
second season plays on a similar
expectation from its audience however
reverses the perspective of a few
elements though the same shock and awe
emotional effect is achieved I think
perhaps even more effectively than the
last in my estimation because it's more
relatable love is a topic often left
unexplored in a lot of these stories
that I've read personally but when it is
attempted it becomes the topic of my
Fascination because in these stories
that so often deal with a Coming of Age
love is one of the most crucial pillars
to get right in that narrative and I
think mob while not necessarily dealing
with a love directly in this episode did
deal with the broader concept of
relationships the Heartbreak found in
them the fear the nerves and ultimately
the Betrayal all linking back to the
core foundations of this series and
indeed the character of Bob himself
choosing instead to be kind the face of
everything horrible everyone has done
toward him unjustly the basic outline of
this episode sees a young girl ask out
mob after he embarrasses himself on
stage in front of a school mob feels
taking can off guard but eventually
starts to feel good about it and well
himself clumsy as he is through this
area of his life she shares with him
parts of herself through her writing and
then she breaks up with him citing that
everything that happened between them
was just a dare that she had to accept
and ultimately it was a joke I think
anyone of any gender or denomination can
feel the hurt for mob in this instance
and that universally felt sense of her
is exactly what makes this scene and his
actions that follow so seismically
powerful in creating a character like
mob who is scared of most things
conventional and certainly isn't skilled
in any of the adjacent areas one also
created the perfect character to be
brave yo man
ual come back
this gave me chills and honestly I got
goosebumps just talking about it and for
a story that is rooted in the
Fantastical and the grand this small
moment shared between two people is the
most my soul has enjoyed this series
with mob not just stepping outside of
his comfort zone but also opening up to
show a piece of his authentic self to
someone who moans earlier rejected and
embarrassed him that my friends is
Another Hero the musical track composed
for Mob fixing Amy's book is aptly
titled Bob's kindness is so incredibly
wonderful the track starts with
Glockenspiel recorder and Kalimba at the
Forefront all instruments that are
wonderfully sweet and generally pretty
simple all instruments that could be
played by children it really gets across
this sense of childlike sweetness and
wonder weakness and compassion that mob
demonstrates then as mob decides to use
his psychic abilities in front of Emmy
to help her the chorus of strings come
in in an absolutely beautiful Crescendo
of Radiance and emotion this track
paired with the awesome storyboard and
the absolutely astoundingly Sensational
animation really goes a long way in
selling what a sweet and genuine Soul
mob is with his kindness and meekness no
longer seem as false but instead assets
episode two and three when it comes to
animation for this season the level of
quality is evident for all to see
returning to lead the series we find
tachikawa and kameda as the character
designer however this time kamida has
taken on the role of Chief animation
supervisor what is Chief animation
supervisor I hear many of you asking
well unlike a regular animation
supervisor who leads the animation
Direction in an individual episode a
chief animation supervisor provides
those Corrections across every single
episode across the season it's very
demanding stuff and for this reason it's
a royal comedy didn't want to take in
season 1 fearing it might compromise his
ability to do his own episodes however
it doesn't seem to have affected much as
he handles episode 2 himself
uncompromised and my long-winded talk
about episode 1 aside what I'm trying to
get across is that while last season
dealt with a lot of exploring what mob's
power meant to him and others this
season focuses a lot more on honestly a
much more interesting aspect to the
series the inner development of mob self
through the flings he shares the
conflicts of interest he encounter and
the existential crises that manifest
before and all around the young man if
nothing else this story about a young
gifted individual in Middle School tells
the tale of pretty much every single one
of us these years were a transformative
time in our lives where we take the
first real steps to becoming the people
we're going to be for the rest of our
lives and knowing this the author One
leverages the Fantastical elements of
his world to explore the very volatile
part but mundane aspects of our lives in
ways that amplify it for us all to take
notice and understand and while I
enjoyed what this episode opened us up
to with regards characters in World
building by introducing us to a new
friendly it was episode 3's focus on the
inner conflict and development of mob
that really captured my interest all in
all the episode deals with what is for
all intents and purposes a regular few
days as an employee of Reagan after he
sets up his hilariously terrible website
in the first season by and large there
wasn't a huge focus on complex enemies
with complicated motivations in the
spirit world at least not in the same
way that this episode contends with
early on after apprehending a stalker
that manipulated his Spirit wielding
Powers it becomes apparent to Reagan
that mob has changed or is changing
voicing his opinions openly questioning
various aspects of his job and his
actions in an ethical light it's great
seeing Reagan act as this Father Figure
to mob perceptive to his feelings and
his needs but it's the ending that
presents mob with a dilemma the likes of
which he'd never contended with before
in this episode it's the human
characters that are shown instead as
reprehensible alongside the spirits who
just want to live a peaceful existence
quote I'm not forcing you it's okay to
listen to your feelings Reagan says to
Bob and it's this conflict of interest
this sudden shift in perspective that
cuts to mob's core as a character it's a
brilliant episode and one that Reagan
wholeheartedly sides with mob on because
he's always got his back and I kind of
love that however the closing Sentiments
of this episode speak to the
possibilities that might lie ahead of
mob himself if things don't go well for
he fears that if he did go Rogue or did
the wrong thing there'd be no one who
could stop him that no matter what way
he looks at the world no matter how bad
he is at leading or taking charge or
making decisions the Box stops at him
because ultimately he's the only one
with the power to make that difference
it's a very sobering thought indeed for
the episode to close on and one that
leads us perfectly into episodes four
and five similarly in structure to the
first season episodes 4 and 5 play host
the first multi-episode story that
concerns Our Heroes with the first three
acting as sort of Standalone tales that
reinforce the themes we'll be talking
about henceforth episodes four and five
contend with really what is an
interesting but straightforward premise
a rich guy gathers every psychic he can
to help his daughter out of some sort of
possession through exorcism or something
and I was really excited to see what
sort of story would manifest from such a
simple premise and I wasn't disappointed
firstly on a music front the track
titled release or restraint that plays
in episode 4 around the 9 Minute Mark is
compositionally and contextually pretty
interesting but moreover acts as the
musical representation of the scene in
hand it starts off as this genuinely
creepy and unnerving piece as various
timbres of piano play over a soft
sustaining synth it very much does its
job at giving us this creepy Vibe for
the miss Street ghost that's possessing
this young girl but as The Scene goes on
and abruptly switches to the POV of the
ghost itself and his boredom of dumb
hack psychics the music transitions to
this off-kilter faux comedy music a
sloppily play Trombone comes in over the
top of the piano that is still playing
from the earlier section and
purposefully off-beat drums are
introduced these weirder elements that
are added give the POV shift this sense
of everyone here is irrelevant compared
to this ghost feel while also
maintaining a sense of creepiness and
Dread as the piano element from the
beginning of the track remains at the
core of the piece just like the
possessed girl Remains the centerpiece
of her scene despite being surrounded by
irrelevant wannabe psychics I love music
stuff like that it tells a story if you
really pay attention and it's honestly
brilliant after this there's a nice
character moment for Reagan winning the
rock paper scissors but actually gets
something out of the young girl that
outs her as a demon possessing a host
immediately rather than beating her in
the bush with her lies and such amidst
all of these fakes and legitimate
psychics up until mob engages Reagan is
pretty much the only one to get anything
of substance from the situation with the
only meaningful impact anyone else makes
coming in the form of them acting as a
host for the possessor to communicate to
the greater group I love how one the
author makes Reagan so damn cool that
every opportunity he has and even when
he's gotten the upper hand on it's after
landing an hilariously awesome e-strike
of all things we quickly learned that
Megami keiji is a famed psychic of the
20th century and has possessed this
little girl dimple has history with him
but managed to escape but that's sort of
secondary the real thing that I want to
kind of focus on is that things get out
of hand quickly for the first time mob
can't stop the bad things from happening
at his will he's not strong enough or at
least the gap between mob and kg isn't
so significant that Bob can gain the
upper hand easily kg beats up the crowd
at will Mob eventually steps in in a
more serious fashion and all that
exploration into mod being more
introspective and less Meek translates
nicely into him as setting the situation
here and taking it seriously from the
onset he even uses techniques he learned
from prior episodes in this season like
that which the stalker in episode 3 used
back Emmy this is awesome between Reagan
mobs maturity and even dimples [__]
crazy heroics this episode 4 is filled
with brilliantly authentic character
moments when mob eventually meets kg in
a plane of existence that depicts them
how they see themselves it's interesting
to me at least how mob's Farm is
depicted then kg looks normal as Bob
says but Bob himself seems I don't know
a little exposed and I think exposed is
a great word here but perhaps indicative
of the fact that he's not entirely
comfortable exposing his powers and by
extension himself in moments like this a
moment that quickly turns into a
nightmare as kg casts mob into an
illusion one where his powers no longer
exist
if you thought I liked episode 4 episode
5 is a full-blown existential crisis
that I've been thinking about since I
first finished the episode placing our
little hero in a world filled with heart
and depression trying desperately to
force mob to grow resentful through a
sense of Injustice and powerlessness
this episode is a fever dream or should
I say nightmare with the only little
tidbits that keep me hopeful are the
pieces of dialogue Reagan offers during
this madness when we get glimpses into
the outside he says Bob is someone who
can solve things on his own he actually
has strength unlike me to hear someone
like Reagan say that it's it's brilliant
I just I smile ear to ear hearing him
say things like this the way this
nightmare is depicted is horrifyingly
familiar and all too real and honestly
it all feels kind of like a Dreamscape
or a nightmare Escape depending on your
persuasion in the dreams we all
experience we often go through moments
of intense realism only to suddenly
shift and switch scenes Without Really
noticing herself all the way to extreme
surreal visuals and this particular
illusion that bobzin is no different out
of everything that's been directed in
the prior season and thus far in this
one this episode is the one that I think
has the best combination of captivating
boards that are married to the themes of
what drives this story forward watching
as mob is robbed of every ray of light
he's managed to cultivate in his life
all replaced with sorrow and hurt is
soul-crushing to see unfold worse again
when this emotional and physical torture
begins to manifest in a fashion that kg
is looking for presented Revenge all of
these horrible traits that map has
actively made sure were not part of his
life before suddenly come boiling to the
top
all right leave it to Dimple to remind
mob of who he is and how far he's calm
you couldn't get a better physical
representation of what mob offers a
human being or in this case spirit in
this series the individual that has
changed the most in this series funny
enough has being dimple and in this
episode it's emphasized that it's been
through mob's example he was flattered
that mob would trust him with something
as precious as his body in the first
place and interestingly there's
virtually no music in the first part of
this episode I noticed and that has to
be a 100 purposeful Choice as the lack
of Music really helps sell this sense of
emptiness and isolation mob experiences
as he navigates the fictional World kg
has created before him having come to
his senses mob finally delivers perhaps
the best line of the episode The shigayo
you fabricated might succumb to you but
I won't I'm not going to run he's not
the helpless joyless and friendless
person kg wanted him to think he was he
knows he's more than that and can blazes
his own trail command his own destiny
and moreover because he's the one with
the power that can stop him he will but
to be honest the episode is known for
one thing and honestly I wouldn't be
surprised if it was only known for one
thing only I can talk about the story
and the music all I want but if I don't
talk about the breathtaking animation on
display that takes place after here I
won't be doing my job correctly episode
5 is
unfathomably incredible to the point of
being enough to fill 30 minutes of video
on its own I mentioned hakuyu going in
season 1's video for his incredible
animation in episode 11 and know that he
was a remarkably young Prodigy and since
that first season up until this episode
he had worked on Episode 22 of Fate
Apocrypha boarding directing and leading
the animation resulting in one of the
most astounding action episodes of anime
maybe ever it was an industry-wide event
upon release with every animator and
director Under the Sun talking about it
and that's important because he quite
literally does it again here and with
arguably more nuance and finesse the
first half of the episode is
introspective and he opted to use a
cinematic aspect ratio to create a
feeling of other worldliness with a
heaping load of layouts that emphasizes
mob's loneliness we even get creepy
looking angles like this dotted across
the episode to elude or hint towards
kg's ever-present watchful eye typically
an anime episode will have a production
assistant credited and part of their
role is to assemble staff for an episode
in this episode everyone was brought
together through goes connections
exclusively and as a result there is no
production assistant credit which I
think is kind of amazing on the
storyboard front we have an incredible
toy affiliate in the form of Masami Mori
who many will know for One Piece here he
draws the most ludicrous effects driven
sequence with insane fabric work he's
pretty well known for his drawings of
funny stick insect characters which is
plain to see in this other scene on the
episode and honestly there are far too
many animators to highlight in this
first half alone but if I had to
highlight just one more this specific
highlight comes from takuji Miyamoto
someone mentioned briefly in season 1
but who really comes alive here he's a
student of shinya ohira a legendary
expressionist animator many will
recognize from the animatrix and that
very DNA can be found here in this
insanely loose and wrapping scene and
all of this is amazing but I haven't
even gotten a chance to talk about the
action in the second half and so I'm
Gonna Leave the less action-packed stuff
behind me for now because I fear that if
I do not I will be here all day there's
an endless number of All-Star animators
to talk about okay so let's go hakuya go
I touched on him earlier but in addition
to everything he's already offered this
episode he also somehow found time to
animate this insane sequence kaichiro
Watanabe is another huge name that's on
this list and he is such for his work on
Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen and Chainsaw man
recently and here he goes wild with his
effects drawing creating such a
horrifying depiction of the spirits
almost like warping bacteria it all
culminates with the introduction of
Weyland Zhang who animates just the most
ludicrous display of effects this guy is
17 years old okay I'm grabbing my mic I
want to reiterate he is 17 years old I
don't even know what I was doing at 17.
imagine being this talented and you
can't even buy alcohol his work on
boruto is some of the finest action who
ever brought to screen he just can't
stop blowing Minds wherever he appears
it then all wraps up with character
animator extraordinaire toshiyuki Sato
putting together this Goosebumps
inducing scene of minori breaking down
he was also mentioned in season one for
emulating one style at the end of the
final episode and yeah there's just so
much subtle Brilliance to character
acting that I love action animation is
flashy by Design and by extension
receives the Lion's Share of the praise
going around online but tremendous
character animation being able to
capture the emotions of the moment so
perfectly requires a delicate but
powerfully skilled touch the likes of
which only the very best of the best can
achieve to this degree and while that
will largely do it for the games I'll
drop in this episode it cannot be
overstated just how little this even
begins to cover the insane and I do mean
insane amount of Talent on display in
this episode and interestingly this was
the first episode of this series to be
made and was completed long before it
aired due to heoko being required to
leave Japan and head back to Taiwan for
mandatory military service which sounds
scary on its face but apparently he
treated it like a holiday which maybe
says more about what the working
conditions of the Japanese animation
industry than anything else I could
possibly say henceforth episode 6 and 7.
this is a collection of episodes or mini
Arc unlike any other in this series I've
seen and because of that I think this is
up there as one of the single most
important or some might say best parts
of the mob psycho 100 story it's a
pivotal turning point or culmination of
where we start out our journey in season
1 episode 1 and moreover made me cry
like when my ex-girlfriend broke up with
me only in a happy way okay that didn't
make sense but this Arc definitely makes
sense and another thing that sets this
one apart from all the other episodes is
that Reagan is the primary character of
focus the main character of the story as
we see how he came to be before he and
MOB ever met after a very brief
flashback from where Reagan came from in
his prior business we Flash Forward to
present day as mob is being celebrated
by his club for having gotten stronger
and I can see why to be honest 35
push-ups is a really solid effort for
someone with no athletic ability
originally seeing him personally reflect
on how far he's calm and how it's been
so long since he was in a friendly group
setting like this is equal parts
heartbreaking and inspirational and
that's really mob psycho in a nutshell
then it finally happens Reagan calls mob
in the middle of a celebration of sorts
right before he had plans to go play
karaoke with people Reagan calls on
short notice and MOB says for the first
time no his request initially and Woody
this all feels natural after the
development mob has undergone since the
very first episode of the series and the
parallels are there to be seen for us to
look at especially now that we can
contrast them with this short note of
stuff Reagan has been pulling normally
working out great for him however this
time despite Bob showing up to bail him
out just this once it results afterwards
in the conversation or should I say
confrontation between the two and let me
tell you it's as in throwing to watch as
you might think Reagan runs his mouth
like he does best trying to maintain
priority in mob's life for his business
but mob fighting back if even faintly
for the very first time is more powerful
than anything Reagan could lob at him
and when I first got to know these
characters in season one I was very
interested in their Dynamic theirs is
very much a relationship forged on
Mutual benefit mob offers Reagan
legitimacy to his business and Reagan
offers mob someone to spend time with a
friend however asmob grows as a person
what Reagan offers becomes less and less
valuable and that's what I understood
after the first episode concluded with
Reagan himself acting as a force that
pushes mob away from things that
directly align with his own
self-interest suggesting he not join a
club in episode 2 in lieu of focusing
all of his attention on his business but
if it was just that simple I wouldn't be
talking about it like I am right now for
Reagan has demonstrated more than once
that while he is a con man he does
sincerely care about mob and his
well-being so there is a tremendous
amount of nuance here but what's
interesting about this fact and indeed
these episodes in season 2 is that every
instance that Reagan helped Bob in this
series there could always be a
metaphorical thread identified that
linked that caring Behavior to his own
self-interest in some way or at least in
a neutral way at the very least why go
save mob in The Hideout at the end of
season 1 and offer him a life-changing
responsible advice well because he
stands to benefit from Mob returning
safely from this interaction why take
mob's side in the woods with those teens
at the beginning of season two well
because it's bad for his business if
mob's heart isn't in it why help him in
episode 4 and 5 of this season well
because he's incentivized to now before
I get comments saying that this is a
very uncharitable way of looking at it I
agree it is uncharitable and I am of
course not trying to suggest that he
didn't want to help Bob simply because
he cares about him either but it's also
important to understand that making
these caring decisions towards mob also
happened to benefit him personally in
the long run and so what makes these
episodes in my mind so fascinating is
that it is the very first time Reagan
needs to make a 100 altruistic call one
that isn't beneficial to him or even
neutral towards his business in this
moment his advice to mob should be go
spend time with your friends but he
doesn't say that instead he doesn't
focus on what Bob's best interests are
and the best part about this is that Bob
notices and so after a few ill-measured
words from Reagan towards mob a fissure
between these two starts to form and as
time passes Reagan is the one who feels
isolated not mob with this episode
showing their respective realities side
by side on one side mob has decided to
focus on his own personal development
and so he's reaping what he's sown there
seeing all the positive benefits whereas
Reagan just has it it's here he actually
realizes that outside of his job as a
psychic he doesn't really have much else
to go on and with a quick peek behind
the curtain and a depressing email from
his mom offering a window into this sort
of existence he is very much alone and
it's quite sad scenes where mob is doing
karaoke with his friends are contrasted
harshly with Reagan slumming it in a
familiar dive bar at the corner of
nowhere he thinks to himself that he
doesn't have friends the bartender
didn't put alcohol in his drink which is
funny because it just reinforced the
sort of spiral Reagan is on right now
with his reactions as he stumbles and
vomits his way under that particular
encounter thankfully though this isn't
an entirely sad story and Reagan uses
this moment of isolation as one of
clarity instead choosing to lift himself
up and focus on doing what good he can
and by doing so broadens the scope of
his business gains more fulfillment as a
person and funnily enough gains wider
popularity this is what personal growth
looks like and eventually he even gets
invited onto television where a familiar
guest plans his revenge on Reagan I
think from this episode the main
takeaway is that while being mutually
beneficial and providing what the other
needed they also in a way Shackled each
other to a specific point in their lives
unable to pass that mob focusing his
attention on self-improvement and
interpersonal relationships but on
Reagan and Reagan similarly not focusing
on bettering himself or changing but
staying the same remaining in Comfort
which Rings true to the overall message
of mob psycho 100 story if you want to
better yourself and grow you have to
step outside of your comfort zone both
parties in this instance have now done
just that and the results I think speak
for themselves but that doesn't mean
that all of that personal growth doesn't
unearth something else uncomfortable for
Reagan to contend with
foreign
[Music]
you know when you're watching something
really embarrassing happen to someone on
stage live and it makes you feel
immeasurably uncomfortable by
association well this is the first time
something like this has happened to me
while watching an anime this is a
fictional character and I'm fully aware
of that and I was feeling all sorts of
ways when I was watching Reagan
absolutely humiliate himself as this
thing was revealed that he was faking it
all along and this feeling for me
happened because of how I feel about
Reagan as a character and how he's been
built up a slick talker that can weasel
his way out of any situation with his
conic and seeing all of that bravado
crumble around him for the world to see
created an incredibly visceral reaction
for me as a viewer this combined with
the public outrage and Fallout as well
as his mother's increasingly concerning
and intimate emails it's a phenomenally
effective way to immerse Us in the
circumstances of this character and the
forces that are pulling him through the
Avenues he's pursued he's trying so
desperately to be something that he's
not and during a press conference that
he holds an essay he wrote as a student
is exposed titled I want to be somebody
I think that says so much about Reagan's
character it cuts right to the core as
an audience we know very little about
his past but the little we have garnered
from him through the advice that he's
offered Bob in the past good or bad
paints him as someone that didn't attend
any clubs after school or really had any
meaningful relationships with people and
upon reflection of this he remembers
back to when he was at a Crossroads
about to quit being a psychic altogether
after just starting and that's when mob
came into his life
foreign
[Music]
this is the moment Reagan recognizes
exactly what he was doing to mob was bad
and In This Moment of clarity contends
with correcting what he said to mob
straight to the camera without context
and upon doing so the conference and the
conflict he's facing both internally and
externally extinguished in spectacular
fashion it's the LIE the character holds
to be true that once that lie is
rectified and acknowledged suddenly
everything becomes much more simple only
in the case of mob psycho 100 it's very
visually and physically and literally
taken care of right before his eyes and
fittingly this might be my favorite use
of Music in the entire season personally
when the entire press conference erupts
in psychic powers it is meant at first
viewing to be perplexing and a bit of a
mystery as to what exactly is happening
I think it is really clever that for
this scene we get mobs thing or at least
we do sort of with one key difference
the scene instrument that leaves this
entire musical Arrangement that we
associate with mob is nearly completely
absent but we can faintly hear it with
it not blaring its trademark creepy
Melody I think it still manages to
deliver this General sense of psychic
powers that we have associated with the
track while also managing to suggest
that while mob is very much doing this
he's not close by any means and that has
of course suggested by the distant and
faint sound of the sea Moon instrument
and I think that's just super clever
furthermore I also think subconsciously
it makes us think of mob right before we
see him and Reagan beat following this
conference which brings me to the final
scene of this mini Arc the climax and
culmination of everything these two have
been through and it's utterly perfect
it's moments like this that I personally
live for in storytelling it's why I read
watch and listen to stories the
Fantastical elements of this tale while
captivating and flashy only act as the
canvas for which this intensely
emotional and personal story is shared
upon this is as much a story about
psychics as The Lion King is a story
about lions or the Shawshank Redemption
is about prisons if those were your
takeaways from those films then you have
a very shallow interpretation of what
those stories are actually about mob
psycho 100 is a story about personal
growth friendship and the expression of
these human feelings outwardly of course
mob always knew what Reagan was of
course Reagan felt like he needed to
light a mob to be worthy of his time and
of course mob stuck around not for the
snake oil Reagan was selling but instead
the shoulder he offered in Earnest and
the kindness that was so intrinsically
part of what makes him Reagan a
character his insecurity and his
business clouded his judgment but true
to mob and who he is he always has the
ability to see things that others can't
this case he saw the genuine good person
Reagan was even when Reagan himself
didn't see it I don't think anything is
more true to their Dynamic both
literally and metaphorically than that
right there there this final scene of
this episode is for some the emotional
highlight of this entire series and boy
does this insert song really help to
sell the emotion of this scene the
insert song is entitled gray sung by
saju nohana the singer behind the op and
it's actually not even the first time
we've heard it this season it was used
in episode 1 of this very season at the
very end and I think it's understandable
why in both scenes it was used to
demonstrate the similarity in mob's
incredibly Meek kind spirit and to
Growing emotional maturity I think the
way it is used in this episode in
particular is especially fantastic the
way we are hit with the guitar harmonics
as mob tells Reagan he is a genuinely
good guy crescendos into the following
Montage of Reagan and Bob together and
that gives me chills just even writing
about it right now these are my favorite
episodes so far and honestly it's not
even close we've gone on a wonderfully
long and action-packed journey with
these two characters and this for me
this right here is the resolution to one
of the most fundamental aspects of this
season a Duo that was once held together
by tenuous deceit and codependence now
flourishes in a magnificent and Lasting
friendship built on the foundations of
what kept together partially in the
first place
all right we're finally here the final
stretch of episodes and it is distinct
from all the others as it's the longest
stretch of episodes that contain One
Mini Arc or telephones solid story
normally in the show we're greeted with
Standalone episodes or couples of two or
even four sometimes at the end of season
1 but this however takes up almost half
of the arc and in doing so delivers what
I think has to be the main conclusion to
most of mob's personal development as a
character and really it acts kind of
like the climax of even season 1 and 2
combined it screams final Arc of the
series and yet season 3 somehow exists
which makes me even more curious about
that but I digress this was a thrilling
and intense set of episodes and
fittingly it kicks off quite the
opposite with an episode that wouldn't
look out of place in a slice of Life
anime mob wants to place in the top 10
in his school's 5 kilometer race to
impress his crush with some of the
highlights in this episode being Reagan
taking time off of his work to help mob
with this race it's wholesome and on the
day at the starting line he falls
scrapes his knee and keeps running and
look it's not pretty but speaking of
someone that sucked at almost every
sport in school and then took up running
long distance later I loved this episode
and what I kind of said about mob as a
character the animation of mob running
towards the camera losing ground only to
regain it is a brilliant way of
depicting just how exhausting and
mentally draining running long distances
is concurrently and despite not reaching
his goal mob improved enough such that
he was on Pace to make the top 70 or so
an enormous Improvement on his 291st
bottom 10 spot placing from last year
that is if he hadn't passed out no I've
never passed out while running but the
level of determination combined with the
sheer amount of effort you would need to
be exerting to make that happen in the
first place especially during a five
kilometer race I can only imagine mob is
one really tough kid I can absolutely
see what the body Improvement Club sees
in them it's inspirational but on that
note this is when the final section
turns up the heat
[Music]
it's a tense and troubling event but one
dimple can thankfully pull him back from
and while he does Go full blown
Terminator on everyone until he finds
answers once he does realize that Reagan
was a victim as well as all the
neighboring psychics he explains that
mob's parents weren't the ones burning
in his home which brings about the most
human reaction from up I think I've ever
seen in this story
oh
all right so as many of you might have
gathered it during this moment in the
story Bob fainting is sort of a way for
one the author to build tension before
mob Awakening at some opportune moment
later in the story I love stuff like
this but it did make me think back to
other parts of this story and indeed
other instances from one's other work
but I'll touch on that a little later
effectively this is the point in the
story where all the allies and
friendships mob has built over the last
two seasons Doctors show what they're
made of and honestly some of my favorite
character moments and scene writing is
in here too I don't want to go over
absolutely everything that happens
between now and MOB waking up but I
think the scramble to make sure his
unconscious body is safe while he rests
is hilarious and at times a tense plot
device so let's talk about my two
favorite moments while Suzuki toshiro's
goons introduce themselves to tarot and
everyone gradually tearo and the rest of
the former scars launched their offense
of all the while Reagan Waits behind for
Bob to wake up he's been out cold for a
while and this is when Intruders forced
their way into the building and force
Reagan to hide with mob still
unconscious
oh
this is perhaps one of the best
callbacks or something I barely noticed
or remembered from season one
what an incredible save that only he
could pull off I was certain he and MOB
were screwed in this instance and he
even manages to take down the big guy
okay so he wakes up and the action that
ensues with the primary focus being to
protect mob is one of the most
infectiously exciting humorous and oddly
10 scenes in the series particularly
when Reagan drops mob that hulking
massive steroid field insecurity moves
to crush him and dimple Saves the Day by
leaning into action to possess Mommy's
body I wasn't expecting this again and
stuff like this callbacks to Prior
events and implementations of already
explained abilities are exactly the
elements that make for terrific
surprises and compelling action set
pieces this is such a short but such a
brilliant scene I just had to gosh about
here unfortunately though dimple's
possession does Come Undone and flying
through the sky mob's unconscious body
lands in the arms of none other than his
Jim bro besties I mean okay look I gotta
call this beta Spade here I cannot deny
that something like this happening isn't
an astronomically unlikely event to
occur and is sort of contrived what are
the odds that they'd be the ones to
catch him even if their running route
was disrupted probably next to
impossible so I have to take points away
for that but
okay uh the best part is know that
everyone has exhausted all of their
energies and powers to stop this guy
from causing undue harm to mob they've
all proven themselves and so we finally
get what we've been waiting for
something I've noticed that's a running
Trend with one stories is that he
orchestrates these Grand scenes of
struggle between forces of Good and Evil
but they only seem to exist in the first
place either because saitama or mob are
out of commission or too far away to be
involved it certainly creates
anticipation absolutely because we're
waiting for Mob to join the fight but
I've noticed that it seems to be one of
the only aspects of one story is that
seems somewhat predictable to me heck
Dragon Ball Z did it with Goku and Namek
are a bunch of other times one piece is
done with Luffy too it's a popular
Shonen Trope but I think they made
enough creative choices in between him
falling asleep and waking up to justify
this choice in my opinion this next
episode is the first in a series of
episodes in which we get to see how
different mob truly is after all his
socializing this season and all the
moments that forced him to mature with
him trying to explain the merits of all
walks of life to the scar grunts these
moments really Echo back to a similar
feeling that we got with Reagan in
season one except Despite All Odds I
think it hits even harder now because
Reagan always like had that I'm pretty
sure he popped out of the womb confident
and convicted but mob isn't that big
we've watched him grow from a nervous
socially awkward kid who gets taken
advantage of at every turn into a sweet
loving Meek person who has convictions
in what he believes seeing him preach
these values to others completely on his
own it just feels so incredible whether
it be with these initial lackies he
encounters with the artificial psychic
powers uh this weird plant man whether
it be by the means of those he
previously convinced or those he's
currently entangled with in combat mob
manages to deal with them as passively
and with his little actual fighting as
he can muster and that's a wonderful
touch and something you really don't
often see in climaxes of stories like
this and perfectly as we transition from
Mob who manages to dispatch these folks
without aggressive physical or psychic
intervention were greeted with this
incredible battle between heru the
Allies guys and ritsu versus shimazaki
the action sequence of all the different
psychics trying to use their abilities
combined with a very expressive and
experimental storyboard make for some of
the most compelling action animation
I've seen in this season and what's more
is the seemingly Untouchable shimazaki
does leave hits through if he doesn't
detect them perhaps he can't keep track
of it all either way Teru notices this
and because of that shimizaki targets
here
and once attack after attack after
attack on shimazaki has landed he still
stands reaffirms control until
[Music]
Bob makes his presence
did I mention that I would marry this
show if I wasn't already married
and one look from Mob is enough to send
this chicken running but the best part
of all is that while this fight between
show and his father is happening above
Atop The Tower mob starts to walk
towards what is no doubt a dangerous
situation alone unlike one punch man
where the drama comes from wondering if
saitama will or will not arrive on the
scene on time mob can be hurt and in
more ways than one he has fears
deep-rooted fears that specifically this
season of the show has explored and due
to this I think that makes tochiro the
perfect and most worthwhile villain from
Mob to face at the end of this season
and really the entire series he exhibits
all the negative traits Bob feared he
might one day exhibit if he someday lost
control that's a big theme in this Arc
Bob learning when it's okay to fight
versus when it isn't when it's okay to
use your gifts versus when it's not in
episode 1 he listened to his heart and
used his powers to save something
precious for another in episode 3 he was
scared it's stiff when faced with the
reality that he has the power to destroy
innocent beings on a whim and because of
that grew terrified of what he might
become if he grew resentful or hateful
who would stand in his way then there
will be no one to stop him as a result
he grew on trusting of himself and his
powers thereafter the Natural Evolution
of this idea then came in episodes 4 and
5 when kg hijacked mob's mind and forced
him into a series of Mind Games curated
by him to torture that very resentment
and yearning or Revenge that he had out
of him that mob himself was worried that
he had inside him but through doing so
through being exposed to all of this
torture and resentment and hatred and
with some help from a friend he realized
that he isn't the person kg or even he
thought he was he is strong and the last
thing he's going to do is run and even
in episode 6 and 7 when this evolution
in the character became even more
apparent and pushed Reagan away
eventually both of them reconciled after
growing as people and now in the final
stretch towards the Finish we've witness
mob's Evolution how his fears took hold
of him and demonstrated how he overcame
each and every one of them becoming a
fine and kind young man in the process
and now standing as the antithesis to
what toyichiro represents a physical
Psychopathic representation of Bob's
greatest personal worry of who he might
become the stage is set for a clash
between two opposing ideals for just
like how Mama spent his entire life
hiding his powers and trying to develop
himself beyond that toichiro has done
precisely the opposite by spending the
last 20 years of his life charging
psychic energy for one expressed purpose
to take over the entire world to destroy
the lives of billions in mob's eyes he
himself is specifically not better than
anyone due to his powers whereas for
toichiro he thinks himself better
specifically because of his powers he
says as much and so now leaving all the
support system behind mob marches
towards a terrifying confrontation a
confrontation with what he feared he
might One Day become and while doing so
insists that his friends and allies
would be in the way he sounds like a
true leader here thinking of the damage
that can be done willing to shoulder all
of this alone however Reagan won't let
that happen and instructs dimple to
follow closely behind in his stead while
show fights his father I mean I don't
even think that's really the correct way
to describe it where I mean like we're
shown that he basically gets his face
pushed in by his father anyway aside
from that we're shown something I
honestly wasn't expecting but it
truthfully made these final episodes all
the more juicy thematically speaking
sarizawa versus mob interestingly this
fight presented mob with another less
evil but still immeasurably destructive
and harmful version of who he could have
potentially been one day a shot in
isolated from society and far too
anxious to ever engage with them
properly due to this he felt shunned by
that very society and became easily led
by the first silver-tongued manipulator
willing to take a risk on him one whose
intentions were Sinister with one really
sweet touch being at the very end of
that engagement when the counter soars
to 100 one that we've seen all too many
times in this series to drive home just
how similar they are the numbers don't
represent Bob but in fact sarizawa's
inner turmoil with mob choosing to
absorb his attack and all the emotion
that comes with it gaining greater
understanding and in turn sends some of
himself back to serizawa so he too can
understand that mob truly understands it
this is beautiful but once again mob
manages to overcome an enemy without
actually attacking them and in that
brief moment too Mama demonstrates that
he has the same abilities as toy Shiro
to absorb others powers and we've seen
that really with the tarot fight in
season 1 2 he has this ability he always
has so it's a really nice touch to see
that this is something that they also
haven't come but unlike toichiro another
difference between them is that mob
doesn't really have any interest in
abusing this ability however upon
demonstrating this technique to toichiro
by lending energy to his beat child
toichiro launches into battle with mob
and acknowledges him as an enemy kicking
dimple to Reagan Below in the process
spurring him to act
little coconut
there's a wonderfully classic and
compelling set of back and forth between
Reagan and toichiro very reminiscent of
the climax of the very first season we
all loved with Reagan delivering perhaps
the best comeback to toichiro I think he
could have ever said in that moment
saying if you ask me you can only see
powers that can't be seen and so I feel
sorry for you that's just the right
amount of bite mixed with compassion in
there for it to be the perfect Reagan
quip however as I'm sure many of you are
already aware this isn't the same
scenario as season 1's finale and we are
reminded quite quickly of that reality
because of mob's actions because he
spoke to and reached arizawa not as a
psychic weapon but as a human being with
aspirations fears and feelings
severizawa through mob's gentle counsel
came to his senses quickly enough to
come to Reagan's rescue at the last
moment what a wonderful scene and what
incredible character writing toichiro as
a result starts to fire indiscriminately
into the city bellowing that he has no
one that he can trust he's a total
psychopath and so it's time to rage this
is where the final battle of the series
begins and man is it everything I hoped
it would be and more mob creates an
arena where he can go all out and in
doing so with toichiro forcing more and
more power out of him mob starts to
laugh and for the first time in the
series it's unsettling the sort of laugh
one might get out of having lived in a
world made of paper their entire lives
now finally able to cut loose without
concern he's just like toichiro he's
becoming a monster just like him
foreign
it's come to my attention after
finishing this spectacular season that
there's a noticeable amount of criticism
launched at this very fight scene
calling it underwhelming visually or
emotionally even and while I can in some
ways put myself into the frame of mind
of someone that would agree with that I
quite literally could not think of a
more fitting villain in action sequence
to play out before them than what we
ended up being served here and now okay
well that's almost true I do have one
hypothetically vague criticism question
mark but before I get there I want to
outline exactly why I loved this final
stretch between the big bad and off I
love that this isn't a fight of good
versus evil it's a fight of Hope versus
the Hopeless optimism versus pessimism
altruism versus ego I drew comparisons
to what mob's character offered
mechanically in season one that was
similar to Gohan's character in Dragon
Ball Z and I'm glad I shared that
comparison because while they do share
that aspect of their character in common
the point of these characters and why
they are the way that they are could not
be more different in Dragon Ball there's
a powerful sense of catharsis with
Gohan's character with he needing to
learn to control his power and become
responsible with it however during the
series mechanically these rage boosts
were moments of release for the audience
to bask in and enjoy this is decidedly
not true with Bob the point of mob's
story is specifically not to use his
abilities unless absolutely necessary
and when he does lose himself to those
darker tendencies that lurk within him
it's framed as a failing in his
character or a slip of judgment or some
horrible circumstance at no point are we
ever happy to see that happen tomorrow
we might be excited in the moment but
narratively it's seen as him losing
rather than winning or embracing inside
of himself there's a scene where mob
genuinely Cuts loose for a few moments
and starts to sadistically laugh to
himself this is the moment I think a lot
of folks were perhaps waiting for but
instead of embracing it he felt let down
by himself and reset that to me is far
more powerful than any rage moment that
they could have conjured up in that
scene with him lamenting instead what
he's forced to do screaming to him you
might not believe me but I really do not
want to hurt you he even says sorry
while throwing a city skyscrapers and
all at toy chiro to stop him and on the
topic of toichiro Suzuki I just want to
say I think his design is rather well
thought through all of the other members
of claw have very Distinctive Designs
and quirks designed specifically to be
striking sarizawa with his hair and
umbrella minigishi with his hair and
weirdness chibata and his Roid Rage and
even shimazaki who is the most normal
looking but still has the Quirk of his
blindness however the boss of the entire
organization is so very plain the only
identifying trait we are given are his
eyebrows and even then those are
probably only there really for the sake
of clarity everything else about the
design looks so mundane measured
unremarkable and to me that only serves
to reinforce further the similarities
between him and Bob neither look too
impressive and could easily be lost in a
crowd visually I love the story that
this series is telling with his
character and the elements that she
choosing to share between him and Mom
but toichiro as a character is far too
powerful to be taken down so easily so
passively he cannot be restrained and
that creates the natural issue and
dilemma for Mob to try and solve he has
so far defeated his opponents with his
words and outlook on life but now he's
met with what is or could have been
effectively himself from an alternate
reality who is not focused on his own
personal growth develop Bob says I'm not
strong enough I don't have the power to
show you A New Path and because he is so
strong because he is so lost in his
vision of what reality is Bob has to
fight him
right
oh and what a fight man in this moment I
[__] cried cried because he's doing
exactly what brings him so much pain
cried because he's desperately trying to
prove that even if someone like toichiro
can be so far gone he too can be saved
and I cried because those exact words
are the Mantra from some of the most
supportive folks in his entire life
friends that represent that part of mob
that's most valuable the part that's
human much like the climax of season one
this final fight here is not really
about who is stronger it is a battle of
emotion conviction and World Views and
the further into the fight we go the
more the music reflects that while the
beginning of the fight had plenty of rad
fight music by the end of it though we
are still watching the characters
exchange legendary climactic blows we
are treated to more emotionally grounded
music with the final fight track which
is actually the theme labeled feelings
are the source of power Bob versus
toichiro is one of emotion and
conviction rather than raw action and
adrenaline I think if I was to offer any
tangible criticism towards this climax
it would be this and really it's a big
pick at best like I said before I
wouldn't change any element of this
encounter but more so rearrange certain
things that could perhaps create a more
effective and cathartic conclusion the
way I see it and I spoke with friends
about this this arkan season seemed to
have two Monumental moments that ring to
the core of the series as conclusions
and interestingly they were placed far
apart from each other perhaps by Design
Reagan's reconciliation and honesty with
Bob in episode 7 and of course the
season's climax in episode 13. both of
these moments are spectacular but for
very different reasons and to tell you
the truth I kind of see why they spit
them up one is very much dependent on
Reagan and the other is very much the
case with mob or so however I do feel
that if one somehow managed to combine
these two moments in some meaningful way
it could have offered an emotional gut
punch and cathartic Bond the likes of
which I've never seen before but as it
stands seven for me was the climax to
the heart of the series and episode 13
the climax to the inner conflict within
mob and the broader World both offer
great experiences and perhaps it works
better this way but normally writers
tend to have the climax for their story
occur at the end together to maximize
the effect it has and I'd be interested
to see what that version of the series
might look like if Reagan and mob's
reconciliation was saved for the climax
of this fight but like I said I think
what they have here is an easy 9 out of
10 maybe even a 10 out of 10 if I don't
want to be an [__] about it plus it's
not like I wasn't reduced to tears while
watching this anyway and with toichiro
saying things like I'm the protagonist
of this world and mob's saying I'm the
protagonist of my own life I think
having philosophical outlooks juking it
out without a more cluttered narrative
in the background was probably a more
fulfilling and focused idea in the end
that everyone made in the end mob stays
with toichiro sits in his barrier with
him underneath all of his guards and he
won't let him suffer ready to Shield the
world from the blast that's brought
about by the delusions of one madman can
mob reach him before he meets an end
molded by his own greed in this this
moment mob by absorbing his power quite
literally absorbs the trauma and pain
from his life showing in that moment the
utility of the bonds that connect people
to others we share pain we share the
hurt we've experienced and In This
Moment mob is trying to do everything he
can to save toichiro from himself I
can't think of a better way to end this
and this might sound like a tangent here
but the last airbender's final season
the climax to that entire series I
always had some issues with but what mob
psycho 100 has offered here is possibly
the perfect way that series should have
ended and it instead does it itself here
perfectly there's nothing more that I
can really say about this climax I was
just left speechless it's perfect and
everything that unfolds after is just
that perfect serizawa feeling like he's
a new lease on life now working for
Reagan under the supervision and
tutelage of mob with a close-up of his
hands fidgeting to deal with anxiety
being one of the sweetest things I've
ever seen God I love this character and
I've only known him for like an episode
and a half this lost toy has found a
home that will love him finally with
this final parting moment from the
beautiful season leaving me teary-eyed
once again there's one season of this
incredible show left season three I have
no idea what they have left to talk
about and I can't wait to see what's in
store for me there when I do see it but
until then I've been totally not Mark
and thank you all so much for watching
[Music]
thank you